françois bayrou le président du modem
est l'invité de preuve par trois rendez
vous en direct que vous propose chaque
mardi public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse bonsoir françois bayrou
bonsoir et merci avec nous donc pour ce
rendez-vous préfère 3,3 grande partie
avec à chaque fois une grande question
la première ce soir que je vous poserai
françois hollande en fait-il trop comme
hyper communicant il est partout il
s'exprime sans cesse stratégie utile ou
courses vaines vous nous le dire et vous
ferez entendre vos critiques et puis
également bien sûr vos propositions
politiques deuxième question que vous
posera des bras clos de notre concert de
la fp qui suit le centre est ce que vous
accusez comme d'autres à droite le
pouvoir de faire monter sciemment le
front national et puis troisième
question avec perrine tarneaud de public
sénat manuel valls at il raison de
repousser d'un an la réforme des
dotations aux communes face à la fronde
des maires et vous-même et bah vous nous
direz comme comme maire de pau si vous
êtes un révolté des dotations voilà pour
le programme ce soir françois hollande
s'exprime donc abondamment il va à la
rencontre de tous les segments où cible
des français c'est le mot qu'utilisent
les professionnels de la communication
et on sait qu'il y en a à l'elysée alors
selon vous est ce que françois hollande
en fait trop comme et perd communicants
la communication tu le sens des gestes
tu la sincérité profonde l'authenticité
qu'on est en droit d'attendre de
quelqu'un qui a reçu la confiance des
français pour diriger leurs actions et
affronter avec eux les difficultés qui
se présentent avec eux pas en
perpétuelle campagne électorale c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
dernier exemple que vous avez vu c'est à
dire cette entrevue bidonné on va le
voir voler avec une dame qui en réalité
étaient manipulés alors que tout ça
était présenté comme étant improvisé à
la dernière minute
oui pour moi ça vous a choqué ben pour
moi ça veut dire que l'authenticité
n'est pas là que la sincérité n'est pas
là et que ceux qui dirigent la totalité
de l'action du pouvoir
ce n'est pas l'obligation de résoudre
les problèmes des français de présenter
des solutions courageuses d'aller
au-devant des obstacles de dire ce que
nous rencontrons ce que notre pays
rencontre seule chose qui désormais
compte c'est la campagne électorale la
perspective de 2017 les sondages qui
d'ailleurs demeure pour cette raison en
berne
on voulait côté on vous l'entendez
encore le chef d'état quand il s'exprime
non mais ya des mois et des mois à saint
médiers soir que françois hollande n'est
pas entendue il ya des mois et des mois
que ça sa parole plus encore que sa
parole son sa personnalité est
devenu très loin pour les français et
que c'est quoi comme vous dites dans
votre langage dans votre langage
elle n'a prime plus elle n'imprime plus
sa personnalité elle et elle est
désormais dans un chemin de huy
d'éloignement d'absence de auprès des
français et je crois que l'un est lié à
l'autre c'est à dire à partir du moment
où l'on ne ne s'exprime plus vraiment
avec la sincérité de son être mais qu'on
est complètement entre les mâts de entre
guillemets communicants moi je crois que
c'est le contraire de communicants je
crois que la communication c'est le
contraire de ce qu'ils font à la
communication ce n'est pas de la mise en
scène
ce n'est pas des propos recopier ce
n'est pas de l'artificiel la vraie
communication c'est le naturel
alors justement il s'en défend de faire
de la communication françois hollande et
françois bayrou vous avez évoqué
l'épisode lucette brochet donc inquiets
cette retraitée qui l'a accueilli dans
son hlm à vandoeuvre les nancy et qui a
fini par par vendre la mèche de
l'opération de com on regarde
je vais continuer à rencontrer autant de
compatriotes qu'il est possible de
pouvoir dans ma position visiter et donc
je vais continuer pourquoi on ne saurait
les il ne serait pas parce que c'est
très important d'entendre justement hors
caméra hors micro ce que les gens ont
dit françois hollande
penser que l'on va chez une personne
sans qu'il y ait des conditions quand je
vais chez vous et hassan deux conditions
partout il ya des conditions et alors
qu'il n'y a pas de caméra il n'y a pas
de radio il ya toujours une franchise et
moi je fais confiance à ce qu'est le
contact direct et peut me faire beaucoup
de reproches mais sur le contact direct
je sais que les français ça me trouvais
alors vous lui faites leur approche de
la sincérité et lui répondant j'ai le
contact avec les avez entendu la phrase
que françois hollande vient de dire hors
caméra et hors micro et la scène à
laquelle on avait assisté auparavant
dont vous avez montré largement les
images c'était une scène entièrement
construite pour les caméras les micros
avec les types qui étaient assis les
notables qui était assis sur des chaises
autour de la table et tout ça la seule
chose qui manque ce soit la vérité scène
par dont la seule chose qui manque c'est
la vérité c'est la vérité de d'un
dirigeant d'une attitude et de naître il
va à la chasse aux voix à mon sens il se
trompe
alors vous dites qu'il n'a prime plus sa
personnalité d'un prime brute est ce que
néanmoins vous les reconnaissez
récemment certain succès au chef de
l'état
on parle par exemple du recul léger du
chômage au mois de septembre également
la nouvelle compétitivité face à
l'allemagne grâce au cic qui l'a mis en
jeu
je lui reconnais de se battre pour la
coop 21 et d'essayer d'arracher une
décision dont tout le monde pressent
qu'elle risque d'être insatisfaisante et
cependant pour améliorer les choses il
le fait il le fait bien
je lui un point positif arracher le
levier chinois lors de son voyage c'est
ce que j'attends d'un 10 as et la
présentation art mais je lui reconnais
d'essayer oui je lui reconnais d'être
dans sa responsabilité de chef des
armées
au fond à la hauteur de sa fonction il
ya des choses que j'approuve des choses
que j'approuve - mais je lui reconnais
d'être digne dans cette fonction
en revanche je ne reconnais pas parce
que pour l'instant je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse s'y fier la baisse du chômage
et quant aux cice j'ai toujours trouvé
que c'était un mécanisme infiniment trop
compliqué pour remplir l'objectif qu'il
s'était fixé
je me souviens très très bien le soir ou
le cic est sorti je dînais avec michel
sapin et il m'a dit c'est formidable on
va créer trois cent mille emplois et je
lui dis tu va en créer 02 de
compétitivité par rapport à la loi
oui enfin c'est reconnu il ya il ya
beaucoup de choses que pour moi je ne
reconnais pas l'autre jour on avait une
annonce disant que l'insee avait reconnu
que le cicr permettait de créer 140
mille emplois alors j'ai pris mon stylo
j'ai fait une division calculette ce
fait une division assez simple le cicr a
coûté 33 milliards les deux premières
années et va coûter encore cette année
davantage que sur les années de
précédentes 13 milliards la première
année 20 milliards la deuxième année je
parle de mémoire je crois que c'est mal
c'est juste et si la créer 140 mille
emplois ça équivaut à 250 milles euros à
peu près par emploi et vous voyez qu'on
peut vraiment pas se vanter d'un
résultat comme celui là j'espère que ça
a permis de sauver des emplois
mais selon moi une baisse des charges
qui auraient été franche et massive
aurait été beaucoup plus efficace
beaucoup plus générale beaucoup plus
simple et beaucoup plus lisible et à mon
sens aurait permis de faire des pas en
avant
est ce que vous espérez encore des
réformes d'ici la fin du quinquennat
dans le domaine économique et social
il y à ce qu'on nous annonce sur le code
du travail alors un le code du travail
quand vous connaissez le poids vous
souvenez oui je l'avais en allemand vous
avez déjà mon genou l'avait emporté dans
une énormément de pages puisque lé grand
nord demain vont être préservés a dit le
chef de l'état néanmoins cette réforme
va être annoncé demain ce que vous y
croyez franchement après les
déclarations successives
on a l'impression que pas grand chose ne
va changer
moi je voudrais qu'on fasse un code du
travail
d'abord lisible par tous sur un petit
nombre de pages mettons une centaine de
pages et robert badinter a montré
qu'elles exigent ça représentait je ne
dis pas que son texte soit parfait mais
il me semble qu'on pourrait garantir les
mêmes droits en utilisant des textes
qu'ils soient beaucoup plus lisible est
beaucoup plus sain est-ce que vous par
exemple vous êtes sur la première mais
si on garde quand garde par exemple le
contrat de travail à durée légale de
travail et le cimic là ce sont les trois
points
vous êtes bourque on garde ce soft vous
me voyez vous voyez que qu'on change de
sujet c'est le code du travail
la question est d'abord de sa forme du
poids qu'ils représentent
du caractère illisible y fait près de
2000 pages du caractère ils lisent 2000
pages en caractères minuscules un forage
d'une loupe pour la lire et ça change
tout le temps
alors ça c'est contre un petit
entrepreneur un artisan une pme qui
évidemment ne peut pas prendre
connaissance et c'est donc à l' avantage
des organisations puissantes des
services de ressources humaines des
grandes entreprises et les avocats et
sur ce point je dis que en effet c'est
une faute après il ya une deuxième
question c'est est ce qu'on doit changer
un certain nombre de dispositions à
l'intérieur et ma réponse à moi c'est
que oui il faudra changer un certain
nombre de dispositions à l'inter il y en
a une que je n'accepterai pas de changer
c'est le smic le salaire mais en gardant
salaire minimum il ya plus dures et les
gars sur le genre après on peut discuter
sur la manière dont branche par branche
chaque entreprise par entreprise on
discute de la durée et j'ai moi même des
idées que probablement je je pourrai
présenter assez vite sur la manière dont
on peut traiter la question des 35
heures mais sur le smic sur le sur le
salaire du travail
non je ne suis pas prêt à baisser le
salaire du travail parce que je
considère que si je voulais aller
jusqu'au bout de ce que je pense le
travail n'est pas assez bien payé pour
une grande catégorie de citoyens et
faire des propositions vous l'avez dit
là bientôt et à anvers 2017 comme les
candidats de droite qui se protège en me
préparant je ne me prépare pas l'armée
mais je parlais de l'élection
présidentielle
dès qu'on aura vu les maires ne
je ne suis pas aujourd'hui obsédé par
l'impression président par le programme
par votre programme en tous les cas
réécouter ya encore dans l'actualité
le programme présidence l'offre qu'un
pays dans une situation comme celle ci
il faut que chacun ait des idées pour en
sortir en tout cas ceux qui sont
responsables comme portant une partie
des courants démocratiques du pays
ceux qui ont quelque chose à dire sur
cet avenir il faut qu'ils aient des
idées sur ce qu'ils vont faire bien sûr
quel moment prendre devant les français
je la préparation d'une élection
présidentielle on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en parler c'est pas du tout
la phase de déclencher une campagne dans
mon ami vous d'accord alors je voulais
vous interroger sur le pataquès fiscale
avec les retraités et la demande du
secrétaire d'état donc au budget dans
kick et invitent les contribuables à
payer
c'est une situation qui inspire
d'ailleurs plantu à la une du monde à
voir son dessin ce soir comment est ce
que vous vous réagissez j'étais une
vraie chien vous donnez pas vu les
saints vous allez le voir un peu l'écart
1 elle râle et conseils à des
contribuables de dire laisse tomber
c'est qu'on en citant les agents du fisc
bon ben vous voyez bien tout ça se fait
dans une improvisation absolue c'est un
imbroglio est une improvisation
l'un se conjugue avec l'autre et là
aggrave l'autre bah c'est la preuve que
tout ça n'a pas été pensé réfléchi n'a
pas de ligne de conduite qu'on est
vraiment dans la
à la non pas au jour le jour mais à la
minute la minute
il suffit de découvrir une émission de
télévision pour qu'on se rende compte
tout d'un coup que en effet un très
grand nombre de foyers par une décision
qui d'ailleurs je le rappelle est une
décision qui avait été prise sous
nicolas sarkozy
votée en 2000 une décision qui change
les choses moi je pense qu' il faudra un
jour qu'on ait un impôt qui soit un
impôt qui touche tous les français que
auquel chaque français soit assujetti
quitte à avoir augmenté ses revenus du
montant minimal de l'impôt vous
comprenez pour que pour que nul ne soit
pénalisé mais que tout le monde
participe
aujourd'hui la côte à environ moins de
la moitié des français - est très vrai
ça sur 100 % bajeux tournée quotidienne
nationale que tous les contribuables
d'une certaine manière participent à cet
effort ce qui veut dire qu'il faut poser
la question des relations avec la csg
qui touche tous les revenus des français
et que donc on met une architecture
fiscale qui soit beaucoup plus simple
beaucoup plus compréhensible est
beaucoup plus jeune que celle que nous
avons aujourd'hui
alors vous avez adressé un satisfecit
tout de même à françois hollande tout à
l'heure pour cent d'actions
internationales et l'engagement de bien
sûr des troupes françaises à l'étranger
nicolas sarkozy selon vous c'est il a
abandonné à la diplomatie parallèle en
allant rencontrer la dmr poutine à
moscou côté g&g vous en conviendrez
assez souvent des relations
conflictuelles avec nicolas sarkozy est
assez souvent un jugement un peu sévère
sur ce qu'il fait mais dans ce voyage à
moscou je ne vois pas il était dans son
rôle je ne vois pas de raison de
critiques non il était dans son rôle de
chef de l'arrivée tous non deux
d'hommes politiques majeurs d'un pays et
qui essayent à sa manière ou qui fait à
sa manière ce qu'il faut pour que les
grands sujets soient prises en compte
je pense que il n'est pas possible que
l'europe soit dans un conflit permanent
avec la russie je pense que la russie
doit être sera j'espère à terme en tout
cas devrait être un jour prochain le
grand partenaire de l'europe parce que
nous sommes sur la même terre 1le la
terre sur laquelle nous vivons nous
sommes voisins et proches de la russie
et il faut des relations constructives
avec la vainqueure bernanke parle bien
sûr de son fait d'armes aideraient s'il
est là c'est la relation avec la dmr
petit oui mais vous la livrer la
causerie nantes jean laurent labit est
le chef d'état de la russie et de ce
point de vue là tout ce qui pourra être
fait pour améliorer la situation
pour exercer une influence pour que
vladimir poutine se conduisent à la tête
du gouvernement de la russie dans une
dans une démarche qui est une démarche
respectueuse d'un certain nombre de
droits d'un certain nombre de règles et
de ses voisins européens
alors tout cela doit être fait mais à la
question
sur vladimir poutine moi je ne regarde
pas tout in comme un ennemi très bien je
le regarde comme un chef d'état qui
parfois à des conduites que je ne peux
pas approuver et cependant il me semble
qu'il faut avoir des relations avec lui
et c'est pas sur ce point que je ferais
procès à nicolas sarkozy alors deuxième
partie de preuves par 3 qui vous donnera
d'ailleurs l'occasion de reparler de
nicolas sarkozy avec cette question est
ce que françois hollande fait il fait
ils mentent et sciemment le front
national on va parler des régionales
mais également de la présidentielle vous
allez répondre à déborah claude de l'
agence france-presse
l'accusation d'arrière pensées
électorales donc répété par bruno le
maire qui fait bondir toute la gauche et
la gauche qui a des raisons en c2
craindre le front national dans cinq
semaines mais pas qu' elle n'est pas la
seule
écouter ce que dit à ce sujet le
politologue pascal perrineau
normalement la droite et le centre
devrait ramasser la mise mais la droite
et le centre maintenant ils ont à se
battre sur deux fronts à la fois le
front de gauche mais aussi à sa droite
le front du front national si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi
et dans certaines régions on s'aperçoit
même que le principal opposant dans un
contexte parfois de délitement presque
de la gauche le principal opposant
pour les républicains lui dit et leurs
alliés et bien c'est le front national
peut-être qu'avant le vote certains
français qui peuvent être proches du
front national hésiteront à franchir le
pas particulièrement au second tour
parce que au second tour en votant front
national ils confieront les clés de la
région
un front national qui jusqu'à maintenant
n'a jamais encore fait ses preuves
voilà pour ses propos recueillis par
flore a sauvagement soir de mort à
claude alors la gestion la question on
entend le front national serait devenu
le principal opposant
est ce que vous pensez comme on entend
ces jours-ci que le gouvernement et le
parti socialiste font monter le front
national est ce qu'il ya des
arrière-pensées derrière tout ça je sais
bien que ça se dit beaucoup moi c'est
parce que je pense et ce que je ressens
le front national monte des faiblesses
conjuguer profitent des faiblesses
conjugués et successives des de ceux qui
exercent le pouvoir en france
alternativement c'est ça qui fait monter
le front national
plus encore c'est pas tant de leurs
faiblesses qu'il s'agit c'est de leur
impuissance
non vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec les
donc et donc je sais très bien je sais
très bien que depuis des des lustres on
va dire des décennies la droite dit
c'est la faute de la gauche et c'est
mitterand qui a inventé le front
national il l'a favorisé un tout petit
peu avec ruse mais c'est pas vrai que ce
soit la gauche qui fasse monter le front
national et la gauche dit c'est la faute
de la droite qui reprend les thèmes du
front national je crois pas non plus que
ce soit le fond de la question
le fond de la question c'est que le
front national est devenu est entré dans
une situation qui est la situation la
plus électoralistes favorable il est
devenu l'opposant universel est-ce qu'il
est surcoté et l'opposant universel
forcément ça ramasse les voit à chaque
instant et donc est ce qu'il est surcoté
non je crois pas je pense que les
sondages disent à peu près ce qu'ils
trouvent dans leur enquête et se dit sûr
qu'il n'y aura pas de victoire front
national aux régionales
est ce qu'on peut en être sûr est ce que
c'est votre sentiment ça signifie que
l'électorat de gauche
si l'opposition
de droite et du centre est en tête se
reportent sur elle en aquitaine il était
à 20% créditée de 20% des voix le
candidat du front national en aquitaine
ya page enfin je ne m'abuse humaine il
n'y a pas de risque extrême droite en
aquitaine c'est une région dont le
tempérament la culture la sensibilité ne
la porte pas naturellement parce que
celle ci avait il y avait risque en
aquitaine alors je vous garantis qu'il y
aurait partout ailleurs de très grave
crainte avec quand vous évoquez les
électeurs de gauche vous qui avez voté
françois hollande je le rappelle est ce
que vous les appelez aujourd'hui ses
électeurs de gauche à une forme de
mobilisation pour le candidat de droite
face au front national
j'appelle à la lucidité vous appelez les
exactes et à la cohérence vous impliquer
tous les électeurs à la lucidité et à la
cohérence
il ya au fond deux sortes de position en
face du front national la première c'est
ce qu'ils pensent que c'est pas grave
ou bien que c'est bien ou bien que c'est
pas grave il ya ensuite ceux qui pensent
que c'est grave pour l'avenir du pays
que les propositions et plus encore les
obsessions du front national mais les
deux comptent pour moi les propositions
sont aussi importants sont aussi
dommageable que les obsessions que tout
cela nous entraîne à une catastrophe on
croit que c'est pour réparer le mal
c'est pour aggraver le mal est donc tout
cela soit lucide qu'ils identifient le
risque maximal et qu'il soit cohérent et
qui tire les conclusions de leurs
analyses ou en tout cas de leurs
certitudes à laquelle ils arriveront que
en effet la ya un risque qu'on ne peut
pas courir simplement pour pour notre
pays et pour les plus fragiles dans
notre pays parce que qui trinquera le
jour où ou qui trinquent e rey le jour
où ce type de deux positions de
dispositions seraient
entrée dans les faits la perte de
confiance à l'égard de la france
la crise absolu de tous ceux qui
regardent la france par exemple des
investisseurs par exemple de ceux qui
peuvent aider à financer notre économie
est ce que vous sentez la mobilisation
assez forte aujourd'hui contre ce
catastrophe que vous annoncez si
l'économie du secteur économique a fait
savoir de prise de conscience entre
aimer le j'appelle à cette prise de
conscience chacun de ceux qui auront
l'occasion de nous entendre ceux qui
trinquent rey dans une affaire comme
celle là dans une dérive comme celle là
ce sont les plus faibles des français
si vous regardez la grèce qui risquait
en premier lieu en première ligne c'est
pas les armateurs grecs cela ils ont mis
leur argent ailleurs
ce qui risque s et les petits retraités
dont on avait déjà amputé les retraites
et qu'elles les se retrouver sans rien
ça c'est le me semble-t-il pour tous
ceux qui ont une
comment dirais-je une conscience civique
et sociale ceux qui pensent que quand on
a la responsabilité d'un pays ne serait
ce que comme citoyen avec un bulletin de
vote on doit penser à tous ceux qui ont
du mal à vivre
et puis à ceux qui peuvent tirer le pays
en avant ses deux ces deux aspirations
et bien cela je les appelle à la
lucidité et à la cohérence de nos fronts
républicains quoi oui je joue j'emploie
ce mot parce que tous ces mots l'affront
c'est ça quand même feront pas ce que
feront c'est d'abord le front national
qui a utilisé le mot est donc on essaie
de faire un décalque je trouve que le
mot résistance vous préférez quoi non je
préfère le mot responsabilité d'accord
aujourd'hui le président des
républicains nicolas sarkozy a mis le
paquet sur la sécurité avec de nouvelles
propositions on va l'écouter et vous
allez pouvoir réagir
nous voulons mettre un terme à la
fatalité d'une autorité de l'état
bafouée systématiquement jeu
jour après jour l'autorité de l'état
doit être rétabli en france tout se
passe aujourd'hui comme si tous en année
comme si la république s'abandonnait
comme si les français étaient livrés à
eux mêmes face aux différentes menaces
alors on va écouter maintenant la
réponse de manuel valls et vous vous
allez pouvoir arbitrer cette polémique
qui monte aujourd'hui
quant à l'ancien président de la
république estime et vous l'avez rappelé
qu'il n'y a plus d'autorité de l'état
après avoir lui même supprimé près de
13000 postes dans la police et la
gendarmerie et les centaines de postes
de magistrats après avoir lui même
affaibli l'institution judiciaire
en remettant plusieurs fois en cause des
décisions prises par des juges
indépendants
comment voulez vous que les français
aient confiance dans la justice dans les
forces de l'ordre confiant de la
république comment voulez vous qu'ils
reconnaissent dans l'autorité quant à
l'ancien président de la république
l'opposition et la droite se livre au
fond à ses attaques contre ce qu'ils
font des fondements de la république
alors de banconi fait reculer la
république monsieur maillot bon cette
polémique que franchement m'intéresse
assez peu et je crois qu'à las beaucoup
ceux qui nous écoutent eu un seul mot de
réponse à nicolas sarkozy le il ya un
chiffre qu'il a lui même dénoncé dans
son discours c'est le nombre de peines
de prison compte qu'ils ne sont pas
exécutées il paraît qu'il y en a près de
100000 mais il y en avait plus de 80000
quand nicolas sarkozy à quitter le
pouvoir
autrement dit c'est une inexorable
glissement curie que nous que nous
étions importante et cette question
capitale j'ai jamais dit ça c'est une
question capitale mais
ça fait des années que en effet l'état
où l'autorité où la justice est
constamment plus fragiles et constamment
plus impuissante dans d'autres pays
et je ne crois pas que ce type de
polémique puisse nous permettre d'en
sortir
si sarkozy avait émis
non plusieurs années s'il avait lui
rétabli là la force sereine et
respectable d'un état qui par exemple
dans les quartiers est présent et non
pas vient de l'extérieur comme à chaque
fois qu'il ya quand il y à une
intervention alors il pourrait
s'exprimer mais je pense que le que les
résultats qu'il a obtenus lui même
devrait entraîner un ton différent de ce
ballet gillet lancé sur qui passa
essayant de ne pas caricaturer mais on
voyait bien mais je me dis se présente
quand la situation
la super mini land l'intérieur la
situation elle est en dégradation depuis
aller 15 ans au moins peut-être plus
sains et donc les propositions
préférerais qu'on soit dans la
reconstruction alors il y en a eu il ya
des propositions de tension armer les
policiers municipaux permettre aux
sociétés d'autoroutes dont vous avez
dénoncer la privatisation il ya
plusieurs années de pouvoir verbaliser
donc donné un pouvoir de police en
quelque sorte à des sociétés privées
donc il ya un certain nombre de
propositions
il ya des idées qui qui sont pas absurde
dans lesquels dans ce que nicolas
sarkozy a dit y compris dans celles que
vous avez cités alors est ce que les
policiers municipaux doivent être armés
beaucoup le sont à pouget doter la
police municipale d'armes qui sont d
arme dissuasive et pas des armes
mortelles
je vous assure que ça change les choses
bien sûr plus d'un ménage sont les
voyants nation doit là là là vous voyez
on entre dans la difficulté jeu ou dans
les dents les sujets qu'il faut aborder
avec prudence
l'idée qu' il n'y ait plus de réductions
de peine pour les peines de prison cette
idée là je vous encourage à rencontrer
un directeur de prison
un gardien de prison et vous leur
demander ce qu'ils en pensent parce que
à partir du moment où vous n'avez plus
la possibilité d'aménager la peine de
ceux qui sont en prison au bénéfice de
ceux qui se conduisent bien et au
détriment de ceux qui se comportent mal
alors vous enlever aux gardiens de
prison et à l'administration de la
prison
quelque chose qui est absolument vous
avez suis d'accord c'est donc sur ce
point je trouve si le que évidemment on
est dans une présentation publicitaire
d'ailleurs qui a fait voter des
aménagements les aménagements de peine
qu'on propose de supprimer aujourd'hui
nicolas ski c'est nicolas sarkozy et
donc de ce point de vue là je trouve que
bon on voit bien ce que la primaire va
être la primaire à une surenchère
elle est là on en a les preuves
aujourd'hui vous savez m'est arrivé
souvent de le dire le ni ni raciste mais
le système de la primaire appelle à la
surenchère et de ce point de vue là je
la trouve dangereuse on envoie les
premiers exemples les prémices mais
pour vous la campagne
on est en campagne de primaire les
annonces à 2 vous pensez que c'est je
pense rien du tout simplement je vous
pose la question
tout le monde le voit bien le qui parmi
ceux qui nous écoutent ne vois pas ce
qui est en train de se jouer
ils comprennent parfaitement à un
français qui vous qui vous écoutent de
quoi il s'agit alors vous devez être
inquiet de l'absence d'alain juppé dans
cette guerre maintenant c'est un moment
la réponse est l'identité heureuse
d'alain juppé non je crois qu'il faut
pas caricaturer je pense que alain juppé
décidé d'adopter une démarche qui est
une démarche plus poser de ne pas se
livrer à la surenchère pour ne pas se
retrouver avec un pays qui aura reçu
beaucoup de promesses mais qui n'auront
aucune réalité une fois que l'élection
aura eu lieu je pense qu'il a décidé
d'adopter un style politique différent
jusqu'au mois de janvier peut-être c'est
pas on verra mais je pense que c'est que
c'est le choix qu'il a faits vous
l'aidez toujours comment oui en tout cas
j'ai dis de la manière la plus claire
que j'étais prêt mais ça n'arrive pas
très souvent dans le monde politique que
quelqu'un qui a un socle électoral
important disent écoutez je suis prêt à
travailler avec elle
concrètement comment voulez vous
monsieur maillot et bien je lai de en
parlant avec lui et je l'aiderai dans
toutes les étapes qui viennent alors
vous trouverez positif et favorable
qu'il puisse comme il l'espère comme il
l'a choisi
donner à cet assaut ce mécanisme de la
primaire une issue favorable vous avez
vu qu'un sondage même si les sondages le
placent parmi les hommes politiques des
préférés des français un sondage le
donne perdant face à nicolas sarkozy à
la primaire mais est ce que ça vous
inquiète s'il passe il vous est arrivé
de m'écouter
l'une quelconque des ses missions que
j'ai fait ces derniers mois et peut-être
ses dernières années vous aurez noté que
cette crainte m'a traversé l'esprit
oui oui absolument pour mémoire il ya un
sens d'amour une raison mécanique
oui qu'il faut comprendre la surenchère
pour la vérité c'est que ça se prête à
ça ou ça encourage à ça ou ça entraîne
en effet à la surenchère et comme vous
ne voyez pas finalement récents succès
donc non je ne je n'ai pas dit ça une
seule poignée pas la primaire j'aime à
la primaire mais alain juppé h ou alors
ça pense que ce système que moi je
redoute il peut au contraire entraîner
son succès avec 4 parce que si le nombre
de ceux qui participent et grands alors
il est persuadé de pouvoir convaincre et
les moyens s'il peut alors je serais
heureux de l'aider
un petit mot sur les régionales vous
êtes
enfin comment dire les modems sont
souvent dans des listes avec les
républicains donc vous allez vous êtes
avec laurent wauquiez par exemple dans
différentes régions vous ça vous pose
pas question notamment pour laurent
wauquiez puisqu'on a vu en a vu laurent
wauquiez aller devant les militants de
la manif pour tous parce que c'est trop
droitier à vos yeux mais sol chacun a le
droit de adopté la position qu'il faut
pourquoi est ce que nous avons été avec
la droite et dans cette élection parce
que la règle électorale c'est que en
réalité à moins de 10%
vous êtes le jouet des autres et que
deuxièmement les règles de financement
font que vous êtes obligés d'investir
des sommes considérables et je suis sûr
qu'il ya beaucoup de candidats qui vont
avoir des difficultés et que ces sommes
considérables
nous qui sommes j'allais dire pauvre
maisonnette où ou pauvres parce que
honnête ou en tout cas sans budget
important
nous sommes le seul parti qui n'a pas de
dette vous n'aviez pas le choix est donc
en tout cas c'était c'était un obstacle
qui nous paraissait d'autant plus grave
que la menace du front national
existaient mais il ya eu débat y compris
parmi mes proches sur sur le choix qu'il
fallait faire et nous avons pas mal de
mer une entame un peu contraint et forcé
on l'a compris une toute petite nation
est ce que nicolas sarkozy a raison de
dire qu'il est victime d'un acharnement
de la justice
décidément c'est le soir c'est la soirée
franchement j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de
débats avec nicolas sarkozy je ne les
jamais soupçonné d'être un femme un
trafiquant de cocaïne
je veux dire que
franchement je n'ai jamais pensé qu'il
puisse être dans les dents les dans les
grands dans les trafics et le et le
crime organisé est donc alors je ne sais
pas quels éléments
le juge avait mais alors franchement
sympa comment dirais-je surpris alors
merci d'abord à perrine tarneaud arrive
maintenant pour la troisième partie de
preuve par trois françois bayrou et on
vous posera cette question est ce que
manuel valls a eu raison aujourd'hui de
repousser d'un an la réforme des
dotations aux communes la fronde des
maires donc vous êtes un jeu rappelle
était trop forte
le président du sénat gérard larcher a
réagi en ces termes il ya quelques
instants sur public sénat c'est d'abord
une victoire pour les communes et c'est
ça qui compte
victoire pas contre mais tout simplement
victoire de la raison en effet nous ne
connaîtrons la nouvelle organisation
intercommunale camille 2016 et voilà
qu'on réforme est une dotation avec
notamment une composante intercommunale
forte sans connaître le périmètre
d'intercommunalité alors heureux il est
clair que nous souhaitons qu'il y ait un
texte spécifique qu'on en débatte qu'on
en discute qu'il y ait gelé dire les
études d'impact nécessaire enfin qu'on
travaille sérieusement sur ce sujet très
sérieux pour les collectivités
territoriales
voilà le président du sénat interrogé
tout à l'heure sur public sénat par
mickaël isabey ce bon soir perrine
tarneaud a cédé au maire en tout cas il
a eu raison de le faire et j'approuve
absolument gérard larcher dans son
expression
on avait des scénarios qui était pour
une ville et une agglomération comme
celle de pau 150 mille habitants qui
était apocalyptique
alors je ne sais pas si c'était exact
puisque personne n'a eu ni quand un look
personne n'a eu l'occasion de les
examiner
comme vous savez j'ai tout rejeté un des
rares
ra a refusé de participer entre
guillemets à la fronde
aidés par ceux des merdeux parce que
tout le monde sait qu'on va devoir faire
des efforts et la ville et
l'agglomération dont j'ai la
responsabilité en font par exemple notre
budget de cette année sera en
augmentation 0 en euros courants sans
tenir compte en tout en ayant absorbé
l'inflation et l'augmentation des
salaires sera en augmentation 0 par
rapport au budget de l'année précédente
si vous trouvez beaucoup de communes qui
en sont la fête moi si vous allez
pouvoir donc on fait de très loin je
peux tenir longtemps
pas si on aggrave la charge voilà on
nous disait qu'on allait peut-être
perdre 3 ou 4 millions d'euros
supplémentaires le point de fiscalité
est à 500000 euros dans ma ville et donc
perdre 3 ou 4 millions d'euros
supplémentaires c'était perdre six ou
huit points de fiscalité
alors là bien sûr il ya un moment où on
se trouve devant une crise insurmontable
et c'est pourquoi gérard larcher avait
raison d'exiger qu'il y ait une reprise
du débat et un travail en profondeur et
c'est pourquoi manuel valls a eu raison
contraint et forcé mais on fait parfois
des choses contre un fils est juste a eu
raison de retarder ce texte donc c'est
un report mais c'est un pas ce n'est pas
un abandon de cette réforme de la dgf si
vous voulez bien réfléchir
reporter 2017 il semble qu'il pourrait y
avoir quelques comment dirais-je
quelques morceaux soubresauts dans voulu
parler d'un enterrement en plus j'en
sais rien mais tu fais un enterrement
comme un cache pas ça je n'aurais pas
trouvé ça bien voilà mais est ce que
cette réforme est quand même nécessaire
selon vous manuel valls parlais tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle du sénat quand
même d'une réforme juste et équitable
oui en tout cas moi je ne la ressens pas
justes ni équitables
est ce qu'il faudrait une loi spécifique
comme le propose gérard larcher pour
réfléchir à tout cas il faut reprendre
le débat sereinement à voir que tous les
élus est entre les mains les scénarios
les simulations qu'on regarde ce que ça
donne et qu'on s'interroge sur chacune
des conséquences sans ça on va tout
droit à ce qu'on dénonçait avant
c'est-à-dire la totale improvisation et
le bazar ce que ce dont le gouvernement
donne l'exemple tous les jours vous avez
l'impression aujourd'hui que les élus
locaux sont un peu perdus entre le
report des réformes la baisse des
dotations la carte des intercommunalités
qui ne verra le jour qu'au printemps
les élus laurie condamne les élus locaux
sont accablés et très souvent découragés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de lisibilité sur
leur avenir
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment que chaque
jour qui passe ils ont moins de
reconnaissance et moins de deux
capacités pour affronter les difficultés
réelles de terrain de quartier de deux
d'organisation de la ville auxquels ils
ont à faire face
voilà l'état d'esprit réel des élus
locaux la leur leur situation est une
situation qui très souvent les désespère
et il ne voit pas d'issue et tout
l'enjeu c'est de montrer une issue et
donc malgré le report de cette réforme
de la dotation globale de fonctionnement
le congrès des maires pour être un petit
peu agitée vous pensé dans trois
semaines
je peux vraiment me tromper mais mon
sentiment c'est qu'on a dépassé le stade
de la révolte
ah bon c'est à dire on est entré dans
une espèce de résignation ne sachant pas
quoi faire ayant essayé des majorités
successives ne sachant pas quoi faire
pour rendre à la vie publique locale
la sérénité et l'efficacité qu'elle
devrait avoir vous plan parle des
communes mais le découpage des régions
est une et une est une injure au bon
sens qui était pourtant soutenu par une
majorité de français alors oui mais bien
sûr si vous dites aux gens on va
redécouper de manière plus logique et
pour faire des économies bien sûr ils
répondent oui et moi aussi je réponds
oui mais j'aurais jamais imaginé qu'on
mette l'alsace la lorraine et champagne
ardenne dans la même région
ne serait ce que pour l'histoire et je
n'aurais jamais imaginé qu'on prétende
que bressuire limoges et pau appartenait
à la même région elle va se retrouver
dans le résultat des élections
régionales alors ça de vrai mais les
français aussi ont une fable
découragement ne vous savez michel une
paire de découragement créer des
conduire à quoi a voté février giteau
qu'est-ce que vous relie wii qui les
conduit à abaisser les bras on va voir
la tentation de baisser les bras
alors vous parlez du basterds parce que
le lait français qu'est ce qu'il voulait
il voulait une simplification de la vie
publique locale on n'a pas une
simplification on a une complexification
c'est chaque jour plus illisibles il
voulait que ça fasse des économies on va
dépenser plus d'argent
et alors ce qui est fantastique c'est
que chaque fois qu'un candidat un peu
raisonnable dit écoutez on va essayer de
faire des économies
le parti socialiste montent au créneau
en disant je prends les fonctionnaires à
témoins avec nous
il n'y aura jamais de suppressions
d'emplois ils ont fait la réforme pour
ça mais de deux 2 pièces qu'on se moque
d'eux qu'elle de dents dans quelle
espèce de du prix de comédie
on se trouve est alors oui la vie
publique locale
elle est profondément handicapée par
cette absence de lisibilité sur les
communes comme sur les régions un pas de
fil directeur dans les redécoupage des
intercommunalités et tout cela est en
effet accablant alors c'est accablant
vous dites c'est un grappin grand bazar
quotidien on a entendu les députés
socialistes qui ont averti gouvernement
du risque concernant les retraités
imposer désormais cette année et l'an
prochain mais bon tout ça a été balayée
par les taxes locales
et puis alors sur la réforme de la
dotation globale des collectivités en
fait on s'aperçoit et on va l'entendre
que le socialiste andré laignel lui
aussi le vice premier président ps de
l'association des maires de france était
sur la même ligne celle que vous
défendez que défend la droite est
aujourd'hui ou en écoute et juillet nous
avions dit que la réforme n'était pas
prête qu il était nécessaire
d'approfondir le travail et nous avions
proposé que cela se fasse effectivement
au 1er janvier 2017 nous avions proposé
qu'il y ait une loi spécifique ou que
s'il n'y avait pas de loi spécifique
soit votée dans la loi de finances pour
2016 les grands principes mais que
l'application soit différée à 2010 est
pour permettre un travail approfondi qui
donne plus de justice plus de lisibilité
à cette réforme de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement alors c'était la même
date à gauche à leur insu laignel a
politiquement raison bien qu'il soit
juridiquement minoritaires on va parler
maintenant de l'enseignement et la
réforme du collège avec cette grève un
peu larvée invisible des enseignants qui
refusent de se rendre à leur formation
justement sur cette réforme du collège
alors avant d'en parler ensemble
françois bayrou on va écouter la
secrétaire générale du syndicat snes fsu
frédérique rolet la majorité des
enseignants refusent la réforme du
collège et donc refuse une
une formation qui n'est pas
véritablement une formation qui est
surtout un dispositif d'information
destinée à leur expliquer qu'ils doivent
absolument mettre en oeuvre cette
réforme
donc c'est un véritable détournement de
la formation continue qui par ailleurs
est réclamée par les par les enseignants
puisque là c'est extrêmement vide de
contenu c'est ça relève plus à les dire
de la propagande que de que de la
formation à la propagande plutôt que de
l'information ce que vous soutenez les
enseignants dans leur refus d'aller à
cette formation la réforme du collège
vous qu'ils étaient contraints ce à
travers la réforme des collèges est une
atteinte profonde et qui se veut
irréversible à l'idée que beaucoup de
français se font de l'éducation
nationale et de la formation des esprits
delà du delà de l'esprit critique et de
la liberté de jugement des enfants du
fait qu'on leur offre une culture
élémentaire par exemple la culture de la
langue pour qu'il puisse savoir ce
qu'ils disent quand ils parlent
ce qui est un élément essentiel de la
reconnaissance et de l' influence et
peut-être du pouvoir dans une société et
le fait qu' on l'enlève aux plus faibles
ceux qui auront pas les moyens de
s'offrir des leçons particulières ou de
l'enseignement privé pour le réserver
socialement à ceux qui aura vraiment ces
moyens est une atteinte scandaleuse et
donc les enseignants ont raison de dire
non et tous les citoyens français auront
raison de considérer que ce sujet est un
enjeu de la prochaine élection
présidentielle arrive pas on va pouvoir
s'appliquer selon vous à la prochaine
rentrée scolaire
non mais elle est en elle et qu'elle est
d'un câble cinq témoins l'armée jeu j'ai
été pendant des années ministre de
l'éducation nationale je connais bien le
fonctionnement des établissements
scolaires demandé aux principaux de
collège la réforme elle n'est pas
seulement scandaleuse elle est
inapplicable parce que
organiser des enseignements
interdisciplinaire avec plusieurs
enseignants sur des périodes de quatre
mois supprimer des enseignements le
latin et le grec rayer d'un trait de
plume
ils ont fait la halle actuelle
qu'importe ce que dit la ministre dès
les options demeurent mais ceci est une
est une blague
vous comprenez pas que on vous manipule
sur ce genre de sujet le le il n'y a
plus de discipline latin et de
discipline grecque dans les horaires des
collèges même solution est donc ça va
disparaître
ce ne sont pas des options ce n'est pas
vrai on dit il y aura des enseignements
interdisciplinaire de cultures de
l'antiquité un enseignement
interdisciplinaire ça dure quatre mois
sur les années 5ème 4ème et 3ème qui
étaient les années où on s'initiaient au
c'était pas de la de la linguistique
évolué et d'ailleurs tant mieux mais
c'était une découverte de quelque chose
d' extrêmement profonds qui est que les
mots ont une histoire il vienne de
quelque part et quand on lui dit quand
on les utilise alors et quand on sait
les utiliser alors on a entre les mains
une arme pour se faire entendre
y compris sur un plateau de télévision
vous comprenez est donc dans un dans un
temps où la communication comme on
disait au début la commune la vraie a
une telle importance
vous enlevez cette âme aux plus faibles
pour le réserver pour les plus forts
comment vous consommez riécois terrible
et injuste oms raciale pourquoi est ce
que le gouvernement serait animé par ses
pires intentions qui vont faire
disparaître le grec est là sur 18 tentés
quoi c'est d'une augmentation du
dogmatisme c'est une idéologie ya ya ya
des forces de pression minoritaire mais
qui depuis longtemps aller dans ce sens
et qui quelquefois aux de s'exprimer ça
donne des textes qu'il est très
intéressant de te lire oui je pense que
c'est purement et simplement idéologique
donc l'arrêt l'arrêt la grogne est alors
idéologique et budgétaire parce que vous
avez ce qui vous
par idéologie et vous avez derrière
naturellement une partie de bercy qui
est extrêmement satisfaite ceux qui ne
s'intéressent qu'aux chiffres qui est
extrêmement satisfaite de voir que adam
va économiser des postes est au fond le
l'intérêt financier et l'intérêt
idéologique se rencontrent se marie pour
porter à un coup brutal et honteux à
l'idéal d'éducation nationale tous vous
êtes un béarnais fait juste françois
bayrou le sénat a rejeté la semaine
dernière la charte des langues
régionales
est ce que vous auriez aimé que le
béarnais soit inscrit dans la
constitution française
d'abord je pense pas que c'était cela
qu'on allait inscrire parce que j'ai le
la reconnaissance ou la mention des
langues régionales est déjà dans la
constitution
et de ce point de vue là on dit le
français la langue de la république dans
le respect des langues régionales qui
appartiennent et j'ai joué à l'époque
en tout cas j'ai aidé à ce que ça vient
telle reconnaissance apparaissent après
il ya un débat juridique on va moi on
n'a plus le temps de l'ouvrir débat
politique je vais le résoudre en une
phrase il faut que les dispositions
légales soient prises pour que ces
langues puis se connaître un avenir
elles sont pour la plupart en grand
danger de disparaître
et moi je les défends g à l'époque que
sauver j'ai sauvé les écoles diwan
lebreton ikastola pour les bases
calandre est pour toute la partie
gasconne et occitane non sur le débat
juridique il y avait sans doute des
fondements je suis pour qu'on trouve un
dispositif législatif pour aider ces
langues à survivre et à se développer
dans le futur
voilà onze ans vous avez avec les
langues et l'éducation nationale un
sujet pour 2017 françois bayrou la
semaine prochaine perrine tarneaud
neutralité sera didier guillaume le
président des sénateurs socialistes
m'ont soir à tous merci et encore merci
à très vite
j'attends